foreign
going to play Anish quickly what's her
call you tour
[Music]
handshake has occurred the first game of
the 2023 feet a world championship as
concluded in peace
indeed whoa what let's see number three
the board H3
some support for thing out there please
yeah it's painful resign every day now I
think who's going to try to come back
it's a drop and check is coming
[Applause]
question mark briefly appeared that
Earth would you allow any of this and
he's already taken
and we saw it on the screen double
exclamation mark move winning brilliant
move being definitely sped up with some
decisions at some point in Jan got
carried away
[Music]
and there we go handshake penguins
so this is like the third category of
move he's not trading uh the light
squared Bishop he's not moving the
rookies instead solving as you said the
problem of the dark Spirit Bishop
while G5 was the punch and I think if
you're choosing between the two
I don't know maybe Queen E8 yeah 28 I
was thinking too is a bit better trying
to
three seconds on the clock
[Music]
you know when I first
okay and I will interrupt my story
because ding has just resigned the game
you can stop the clock handshake has
occurred and Jana palmyoshi once again
holds a one point lead in the 2023 world
championship match even when you don't
need to be honest I expect one C4 and
we're off we have the handshake yes he
does yes oh no oh no oh no the London it
was a very similar situation where you
go E5 F4
we're not going to take C3 I think gave
a check instead
[Music]
Jana has resigned you called it no
beautiful Checkmate on the board but
still a beautiful game Beautiful Finish
from ding
here we go handshakes and he goes with
the French
[Music]
less than a minute
that's it
[Music]
well no London as we were seeing through
C4 has been played oh does he sacrifice
the room
[Music]
beautiful professional idea
wow he's trying to
um Force the Knight back to F6 it was
Knight F2
and that deserves the double exclamation
I mean that was a big decision he has to
make a move 10 seconds one more move
remains
look at him
soaps
there's a drug read Fair result what a
match we have it looks like he's about
to make a move if he make I had to do
sex so
yeah answered your question for us
[Music]
the writing's on the wall
straw
Berry White would win this position
one is going to be a draw and being
there with a smile
we're just strong
you offer a draw in this position
I make that it's a brilliant move and we
see the glyph appear there it's a double
X lamb and hobby he just goes for Rook
to G8 instead
is there what is the problem with this
move it does take care of the threat of
Knight F3 and what does it walk into
oh my goodness the evaluations were all
the way up and dingley Run's favor
ding's Choice he also doesn't find the
best move
oh
gosh
[Music]
even though if you're a ding the Red fan
you're thrilled I think even then you're
still upset for young just because of
you know how he's feeling right now
[Music]
handshakes
we have a handshake the game is in the
books that means we still have a tied
match Bishop D2 and this one as well has
been a topic of conversation in the Nim
Zone question mark That's not clear to
me but this position has made it worse
for white people side so Knight C5
[Music]
and that's it we've got handshakes and
it's a drop in the final 14th classical
game after a marathon seven of five ends
peacefully I think five six decisive
games the match is level and goes down
to the wire the 2023 world champion will
be decided in speed test it will all
happen tomorrow we see the players there
they are analyzing what a fantastic
finish what a big fight this has been in
game 14 and throughout the match it's a
reset it's not going to be easy for Yan
or for dangleren foreign
we see cb6 ab6 has been played and that
was an inaccuracy apparently fighting
the run but the evaluation bar is still
only slightly in Beyond's favorite a
takes music is a brilliant move 25 hang
so he has to stay connected to the Rook
on H1 and there we see what a draw this
has been handshakes the first game not
for the world to see and to enjoy and we
see the handshakes and get involved I
know look at this view Beyond the Palm
Street playing Spanish
look at Jan he knows that there's
absolutely nothing here it may look like
a bad contract they are just moving the
roots around and it's people 's
Renditions and that's a draw agreed
he's not happy defending this position
this is just an easy draw this has been
the most peaceful game
oh the queen two you actually do he
probably didn't see that one it's a
brilliant move oh my God what
point for a win is daily Wren trying to
win this game that was a mistake
oh Queen D3 not even queens before Queen
D3 that's the best way indicating the
point I think ghost points except which
is a mistake a huge mistake in time
travel from Yonder palmchi The Queen has
to go back to G6 that's the good news
for dingley red he has only one move
here
he sits up in his chair no this might be
the last few moves of his world
championship oh my God
see it
he knows it
takes a force
it's over dingler and he is the world
just champion
wow he has made history as the first
Chinese player to win the World
Championship we see handshakes that Ding
is overtaken by emotions he isn't able
to leave the board and for yeah a
heartbreaking moment that he leaves the
hall this has been a fight of Courage of
grit and determination and all of that
has paid off for danger and take a
moment and admire ding right now what a
match this has been and a deserving
Victory or dingler yes 2023 world
champion
[Music]
thank you
foreign